[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george rr martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on georgia martin's book fire
and blood vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1
ended with rhaenyra targaryen's son
aegon iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
ned stark's older brother brandon stark
played a big role in the prelude to
robert's rebellion
brandon stark was the heir of rickard
stark the lord of winterfell
and the older brother of edward lienna
and benjen stark
he was killed by strangulation by the
mad king when he protested
the kidnapping of lyna by prince rhaegar
targaryen
his father rickard died along with him
by wildfire
this brutal act triggered robert's
rebellion the civil war that led to the
removal of house targaryen from the iron
throne
originally game of thrones season 1 was
to feature a scene where the mad king
executes the starks it was filmed and
put in the trailer
but they eventually decided to edit it
out brandon was in appearance and
character very different from medard
he had grey eyes and was tall and
handsome brandon was absolutely not shy
about
taking what he wanted he was rather
hot-blooded
a trait their father lord rickard
described as originating from the wolf
of blood
brandon shared this straight with his
sister lyanna
and eddard believes this led them both
to early deaths
brandon was the best swordsman among his
siblings
and an excellent jouster he loved to
hone his sword
preferring it to be as sharp as possible
he also loved to ride
born in 262 ac at winnefell brandon was
the eldest son and heir of lord rickard
and lady liara stark rickard was the
head of house stark and lord paramount
of the north
the warden of the north and head of
house stark until he was executed
along with his eldest son and heir
brandon by the mad king
aerys ii targaryen the north is one of
the constituent regions of the seven
kingdoms
and house stark is one of the great
houses of the realm
house stark rules the region from their
seat of winterfell
and rickard also held the title lord of
winterfell
rickard was the father of brandon eddard
lena and benjen stark
both rickard stark and the mad king are
grandfathers to
jon snow rickard stark served faithfully
under king garys ii
he was saved from drowning by sir arthur
dain during the siege of white harbor by
the outlaw sea kings
he arranged for the betrothal of his
daughter leona stark to robert baratheon
the lord paramount of the stormlands he
also betrothed his son and
heir brandon stark to catelyn tully the
daughter of holster tully lord paramount
of the riverlands
both engagements were broken when prince
rhaegar targaryen abducted lyanna
brandon was fostered at baroton with
lord dustin
he spent most of his time riding in the
rills his father betrothed him to
catelyn tully of riveran
who considered him to be more handsome
than his younger brother eddard
brandon did not want to marry catelyn
but lord rickard's ambitions did not
allow him to marry the daughter of a
northern bannerman
in 281 ac brandon was present at the
tourney at harrenhal
there he was introduced to the cranong
man howland reed by his sister lyanna
during the opening feast of the tourney
brendan asked the chardaine's sister of
sir
arthur dane to dance with eddard who was
too shy to ask
her himself brandon later entered the
list
but was unhorsed by prince rhaegar
targaryen
after prince rhaegar won the tournament
he crowned brandon's sister liana as his
queen of love and beauty
passing over his own wife princess aelia
martel
brennan had to be restrained from
confronting rhaegar
as he took rehgar's action as a slight
upon lena's honor
since lena had been betrothed to lord
robert baratheon for a long time
in 282 ac brandon was present at
riverrun
when the date for his wedding to
kathleen was announced
peter baelish the word of kathleen's
father lord hoster tully challenged
brennan to a duel for her hand
they fought in the lower bailey at
riveran catlin begged him to spare
peter's life
and brandon promised her to do so
brandon armored himself for battle
aided by kathleen's younger brother
edmurtali who served as brandon squire
vamprena saw that peter wore only a helm
and a breastplate and mail
he took off most of his own armor
brandon was more than a match for the
much younger peter
he offered the boy several chances to
yield but when peter kept refusing
brandon ended the duel by injuring peter
severely
he defeated baelish easily nearly
disemboweling him in the process
but kathleen begged brandon to spare his
life the maesters were able to save
baelish and he eventually recovered
but he was left with a deep scar running
from his stomach to his collarbone
under his clothes a token from brandon
that baelish would always carry with him
afterwards he departed riveran promising
kathleen to return soon so they could
wed
from riverrun brandon left to join his
father's wedding party
coming down from the north they were on
their way again back to riverrun for the
wedding
when the word reached brandon of lena's
supposed abduction by prince rhaegar
targaryen
brandon along with his squire ethan
glover kyle royce
albert terrain and jeffory mallister
rode to king's landing immediately
upon entering the red keep brandon
shouted for rhaegar to come out and die
rhaegar was not present however and
brandon and his companions were arrested
by king aries ii targaryen
and charged with plotting reiker's
murder their fathers were called to
court to answer the charges
aerys ii imprisoned brandon an order
that recurred right south
to answer for his son's impertinence
against advice
rickard agreed assuming that the matter
would be settled through a trial
or a bargain of some kind brandon was
killed on the order of aries targaryen
along with his father after they
protested the kidnapping of lyanna by
prince rhaegar targaryen
must be strange for you coming into this
room
i'm standing right here when it happened
it was very brave your brother and your
father too
he didn't deserve to die like that
nobody deserves to die like that
you just stood there and watched 500 men
just stood there and watched all the
great nights of the seven kingdoms you
think
anyone said a word lifted a finger
no lord's dark 500 men and this room was
silent as a crept
except for the screams of course
and the mad king larvae and nature
when i watched the mad king die i
remembered him laughing as your father
burned
it felt like justice
is that what you tell yourself at night
you're a servant of justice that you
were avenging my father when you shove
your sword in aries targaryen's back
tell me if i stab the mad king in the
belly instead of the back
would you admire me more you served him
well
when serving was safe
brandon was placed in a strangle device
from tyrosh
where a long sword placed just out of
reach he was forced to watch as his
father was burned alive in his
own armor and strangled himself while
attempting to get to the sword so he
could save his father
he was 20 years old at the time aerys
then
ordered john rayne to hand over his ward
and the new lord of winterfell eddard
stark as well as robert baratheon
lord of the storm's end having sworn a
sacred
oath to protect eddard john instead rose
his banners in rebellion
he was supported by the north lyons
betrothed
robert baratheon and hoster tully this
sparked the beginning of the war known
as robert's rebellion
which led to the near destruction of
house targaryen and its removal from the
iron throne
brandon was buried in the crypts beneath
winterfell
although only the kings and lords of
winterfell normally have statue in their
likeness
placed beside their tombs both brandon
and his sister liana were given a statue
by their brother edward
as he'd loved them very much eddard
stark named his second true born son
brandon
affectionately known as brain in his
elder brother's memory
many stories we heard of such as brandon
almost killing littlefinger
the mad king executing brandon and his
father rickard stark
many battles they heard of such as the
battle of the trident
and the legendary duel between robert
and rhaegar during robert's rebellion
all of that and more we'll finally see
in the upcoming game of thrones prequel
house of the dragon coming in 2022 on
hbo
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace